[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ese might be my time because there's a
microphone on this yeah unless you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
switch screens what up everybody we're
just having a little chitchat but now
we're live season 4 of Apex is here our
updates are underway and we're ready to
play but of course we gotta say hello
and good morning and how are you guys
doing
I'm Persia I'm joined by max in Jordan
City or Apex extraordinary and yeah if
you guys haven't seen it by the way we
have our one-year apex extravaganza
video up and it's kind of recapping all
the great things that have happened this
year and Max and Jordan have produced it
and made it happen and all that good
stuff so if you guys haven't seen it you
should check it out we're also gonna
have a lot of other apex content up on
the YouTube channel and very soon but
yeah I think we're ready this looks so
cool so I guess we'll go through the
menu really quick and kind of see what
he has the store is not really working
quite that well right now but we can at
least see his skins mm-hmm his skins are
so cool so it got like the Anubis bird
of prey bird of prey might be my
favorite of his legendary skins it looks
very very cool yeah I like that color
combo so much yeah white always is a yes
for me and then it got the Satan's watch
so many ghosts and like haunting things
and they always talk about the goatman
and I was like I love this and then we
got all of his regular skins you would
get the ones that everyone has
fiberoptic and whatnot but it just looks
really good on him because he's like got
the whole robot aesthetic going on
anyways there's like a part of me that's
kind of always bittersweet about new
seasons because with new seasons comes a
new legend and I'm like ah fresh
assortment of common and rare items
yeah added to the apex of power
of another epic or legendary item 15
packs one time and I didn't get anything
good but my RNG is notoriously bad yeah
so is mine we might as well just write
it up and get into a game I feel like I
have to apologize to both of you since
I'm playing on ps4 apparently for the
very first time so like having the d-pad
above the left thumbstick is just it's
very simply on Xbox all the time because
like I started with like Halo as a
shooter and then the adjustment of using
the analog stick slower made my thumb
hurt because it's like a whole nother
angle is so weird I think if you swap
between both consoles frequently they
could get used to it yeah yeah oh yeah I
get that spooky boy there he is looking
good oh my goodness he's so mean like
really safe already got one quit with
him abilities so got stalker crouch
those
Crouch walk faster and climb walls
higher okay
reminiscent of fight off right yes I
read the article I'm sorry just know
them on top of my stalker allows him to
Crouch walk faster and climb higher than
normal legends silence his tactical
throws out a bomb that damages enemies
and disables all their abilities for 10
seconds so they can't use their passive
tactical or ultimate and his ultimate is
death totem if you and your allies touch
it for a limited time you will just
return from death when you're knocked
down so I already have some theories
haven't haven't even played ascared
there's my first time playing him right
now I'm already getting some theories of
he might be the best poking character
besides Wraith where you can like safely
attack an enemy without like getting too
much
Master let's go how about yeah I'm gonna
drop it
Oh realized I hadn't been paying
attention actually this is me super hot
I don't know if we want to do because
the trains going there yeah um this is
the warm-up game actually there's a lot
of people going to the new city it looks
like really good actually
like I don't see any teams really
following this all right well let's get
to it so I'm gonna try to let the train
give me that purple that's not a purple
that's a flat line which is mine I guess
daddy like Oh prowler I got bumped
I was more talking about the gold body
shield but yes the prowlers oh nice
purple body shield gold backpack and
gold knock down I'll let everyone have a
gold item I can I take the backpack
sorry I'm I need a gun be nice get the
knock down shield
max max no max get the knock dad Chios
are we staying on the train I don't
think so I just wanted him to get it and
if not I was gonna grab it and throw it
off sure appreciate it
you know once played with a Rando who
like got on the train got like a gold
body shield and then just quickly
dropped it off the train and grabbed a
purple and then dropped it also off the
train so that I could get the purple and
you switch back to the golden way this
is the nicest random person played with
I know I feel like over time people have
understood like hey you have to work
together here I mean definitely not
everybody's on the same page though Oh
what kind of Sentinel oh and then we got
the new sniper ammo
okay history there is news tonight for
Emma I'm gonna definitely need a site
with this thing
iron sights not bad so if I was reading
the patch notes right it eats shield
batteries to do it charge cut each
shield batteries I think so I think
that's what I read but I'm not entirely
sure I don't even have the charge
function right now yeah I think it was
like if you have a shield battery you
like inject the shield battery into it
to do like the charged shot interesting
okay well we're gonna figure that as we
go again this is our first time dropping
in weird fresh in we'd haven't had any
practice or not even firing range have
no idea what's going on right now so if
we lose it's because of that why am I so
bad at looting okay I need to go so well
we're not we're not gonna stress it
right now we're just gonna that booty
clap is the new kill leader
because some interesting people in the
law here like cutting a close huh I dig
that oh it's a Sud to sniper mag oh it
is that's pretty cool
okay alright so we're decent on body
shields I would like to get max a purple
if we could I think we should be okay
ooh a guy death told him okay so what do
you say get to the ring or I'll kill you
myself
yeah I just wanted to pick up more heavy
ammo Danny he's kind of a kind of a
meanie reminds me of like the one time I
tried to get a personal trainer and they
were like yelling at me and I'm like no
he's like its motivation I'm like not
for me all right I need to mess around
with him so he crouched walks faster
yeah crouched walks faster and limes
higher I need to find a wall to climb
this is actually pretty quick it's like
30% faster then right so we're close to
fragment East the new right half of what
was once Capitol City we have to go over
the lava River to reach the other side
so you can also go over the river itself
right because it's a defense yeah you
take 25 damage if I remember correctly
and it's a little slow but
I'm all over here I do not have a scope
on any of my guns so this is all you max
I have two submachine gun I feel like we
should loot up a little bit more uh
already been hit oh you know what oh oh
I just got blood hounded crack shelter
captain L star on the Bloodhound knock
there revenant
ah 300 right here right here each week I
gotta me real quick
you have the gold backpack right yeah oh
no no wait she does what I don't
actually have much in the way of healing
I'm gonna use a deaf totem actually
that's a smart idea
oh okay want to touch the totem oh I
have to touch it okay yeah
returned to do interesting ow I'm still
low though
wait okay I'm confused by how this works
hold them hold them
and guys let me behind you okay I got
the squad but we are about to get third
party again oh well if we die here I'll
be happy with that cuz I got a quick
noscope I said Mary
oh it's all you Jordan why oh she has
death too
I'm like she's going Orange a couple
frags it's not too bad I probably
shouldn't have jumped down like that
after that guy - down there I feel like
as least like in fact if I get one or
two kills I'm okay with it but just drop
it die I'm a little soul but I'm liking
him so far you know I haven't even like
use all his skills yet really
I just jump from level 1 to level so I
think okay yeah I thought when I touched
it soda and I run in when I went respond
I would have like full health again but
I had like a pixel yes so they did that
on purpose yeah yeah but I'm already
thinking like your shields mm-hmm yeah
you keep your shields but you don't keep
your health and I'm wondering if you can
like pair that with other Ultimates like
maybe you can use like Rafe rapes portal
so you can like have it ready at the
totem so then when you spawn back after
you die can like attack them again
immediately or something like that or
like escape immediately
just fit a lifeline and bought it right
on the totem so yeah oh you know what
would be really rough is if Kasich put a
caustic trap right next to that I think
the Watsons and caustics are going to
start putting their stuff around yeah
yeah yeah that's cheap because then they
just all pile up at the totem mm-hmm and
they're all down basically oh boy we got
a sweaty guy here all right
all right guys let's do this
all right so you want to go to different
parts of the map bro yeah
do we want to try going to the harvester
mm or we could go straight to the
capital city this time - I could go to
us - the half that's not the Blue Zone
yeah I had to look down to remember
which one is the square button a little
different from xbox oh we got a letter
predator Squad coming in I'm gonna go
farther it's go this way all right I am
sad okay we don't have a gun that's cool
yeah looks like we're punching yep Oh
sadly Oh
ultimate accelerates great [ __ ] go
somewhere
finally there is a wraith with a
peacekeeper in g7 hunting just just
giving you that as a heads-up right
super hot oh I am going to if someone
near me in this direction I think you
just crouch walking to I couldn't you
know I gotta use that more Crouch walk
yeah I mean yeah you can now essentially
move as fast as people just walking and
running but yeah you're silently doing
it like that's pretty good I mean is it
just as fast as it is faster
oh it's definite yeah speed but it's
definitely like I feel like if you're
just normally walking before sprinting
that's like the speed you're crouching
at now which is pretty good really
Crouch walking in this game though is
and as silent as like crotch walking in
cod you can still kind of hear faintly
yeah little like pink I mean you got to
be like especially if you're like octane
you just hear the metal clinking yeah or
Bangalore's cans rattling yeah alright
we didn't keep dropping in different
places then we'll go to the trihard
sweaty position of course all the new
places are jobs I mean I'm just playing
this game as like not sweaty as possible
I think we should just relax and I feel
like no matter what it's always sweaty I
feel like the other players are probably
sweating yes the nature of this game
yeah
stand up and ready to burn second I drop
I'm sweating I keep trying to reach for
my paddles to switch my grenades and
she's like where are the buttons
yeah nice okay yeah I'm still thinking
of getting that elites too serious to
control it's wonderful just to be able
to like be running and switch what you
grenade and yeah you're using without
having to take your finger off of them
stick to change that when inconveniently
out of like although I love the ping
system yeah it's because the ping
systems there that the grenades are in
this wonky spot I mean obviously if
you're a PC player you don't worry about
that type of thing that's way I feel you
re I don't know we're gonna make this
bud we're gonna at least make it you
kind of went a little early to hit
harvester oh well the path was kind of
like perpendicular to it so it wasn't
really gonna matter either way
ridiculous where the day busting out
some old geometry we made it my
beautiful most gun rack knows not where
the gun rack is at a near epicenter in
town isn't it I think it's only a pillow
that's not good nope nope nope nope yep
there's people in here don't worry I'm
dipping I have nothing oh can I use the
vents
nice me though oh okay
that's actually not good [ __ ] I have
nothing oh what a headshot you guys are
completely on your live literally
nothing right now if we kill that Watson
we can get whatever she has renewed Oh
lovely okay all right I've got a triple
tape and I watch you guys for a bit I
just dodged this sniper shot I bet so
maybe what we'll do next time is we'll
drop a little bit away from the hot zone
and then go explore after all the spicy
max always spicy I'm curious if you're
knocked down if you can still ride the
lava flow oh you can still write the
lava for damage but you'll take 25 so I
don't think you'll lose all your health
if you do that the beginning I was
already low health when I did that so
you could go across technically yeah
that's kind of cool an actual way to
escape trip we'll take him dribble take
it with the police nice sure we'll take
us one of my favorite uh starter weapons
just because it's like break body shield
on the first shot and yeah kill on the
second I I don't know I haven't had that
much luck with a triple triple take ooh
don't let him escape jump hat out next
time if I get weapons maybe we can
actually get to play the game
our biggest problem we were basically
two people going against like yes lots
and I don't have no gun basically
already down the [ __ ] got me a kill
cuz I knock someone gee finish them for
me hmm
trying to think what else we can do with
revenant cuz that that's done already
knocks down two people with that with
his little orb thing yeah his orb thing
is actually does damage and silence ism
or does it just silence them I need to
see if I think it actually does silence
them I need to look at the actual the
actual skill just description but I
think it actually blocks their abilities
too so if it does all three things stuns
silences them and does damage that's
actually like ridiculous yeah I mean I
imagine if you're right next to it it's
doing some sort of oh yeah damage I
think it's the damage over time to oh
right that's a great thing to throw out
like just at the start because I almost
got caught in that revenant that you
were with when he gave out his doctor I
was like just behind you and I'm like oh
think it seems like his totem charged up
pretty fast that first game we were
playing yeah it does
yeah after the first time I used I got
it back so not sure if it's a quick
charge might be like I don't know if
it's a pathfinder quickly
okay so don't Eliza deals damage and
disables enemy abilities for ten seconds
so it does all three mm-hmm that's
really cool
yeah okay but he does have low profile
he has the same nerf that Wraith and
lifeline have mm-hmm
fair enough but like if you're just like
moving in on a squad that's like
entrenched and you just disabled their
chance to use it is really good it's
like you're looking at like a wraith
it's like yeah I'm gonna make sure that
you can't all right Persia I see you go
over there the area - yeah the survey
camp that's where the weapon rack is
okay so guaranteed weapon there except
so everyone I was gonna do it I couldn't
tell based on the language if it was
like the same guaranteed weapons there
or if it's really like the firing range
where there's one of every single would
be nice
that'd be nice to feel like more people
would be landing here if that's the case
I see
predator on our squad okay you know now
I don't know which of these buildings
has the weapon racks in it so this board
is the one on the left and I've chosen
poorly no
[Laughter]
I've done here but I'll take it I'm not
a fan along though oh it's right here
on both the earmuffs for this over there
oh shoot oh shoot
he missed he missed okay we're good I'm
scared though I'm really low already
he's in here max okay they're pretty low
oh no I have no ammo Oh God okay I'm out
no so no I have no ammo again why the
heck
all right cop six down I literally can't
do I don't know get a different gun
please Oh
Oh down here nice thank you
oh I'm using Maxis screen to like see if
there's any code on us I don't know
where the heck he is but I'm running I
say they're revenant I think is still
alive okay okay I have no health got him
nice I got anyone there's a flatline in
here and an L star oh the LSI takes
energy ml wait as the else are just a
standard weapon now yeah yeah it's a
standard weapon though I actually
thought I picked up the charged rifle
and when I started firing it I was like
oh this is what I wanted right so which
one of these has the weapon racks in it
because I could have sworn they said
this was the location with the weapon
racks it was over in this building over
here
were there any guns on it uh yeah there
are three guns I don't know if it
randomizes oh there's some over here too
oh okay reminiscing Mozambique Aires oh
they didn't nerve to g7 though but it's
fine just a longbow and a habit all
right well I need to find dealing we do
need to find some much more stuff though
cuz it's impossible to make someone
truly evil in this game make him so
personable yeah I desperately since
caustic now is kind of talking about
revenant when he has that whole thing
where he looks like I feel most alive
when I'm rapidly approaching my dad I
hope that there's fan art being made
right now that shows caustic running
into remnant what is this trash this
hyper ammo is blue yeah so that's now
dedicated to the Sentinel and the
longbow and all that stuff whoo hammer
point I could use that it's so weird
that g7 it's not a what I call it
assault rifle anymore I mean a sniper
anymore it was assault rifle that's an
assault rifle now yeah basically DMR so
they basically reverted back to what it
was and titanfall to all it was yeah
wasn't an assault rifle they changed it
to a sniper rifle for apex legends I
know I'm triggering people right now
I'm saying I haven't played titanfall -
yeah I remember being very surprised by
that when we talked about season 3 I
mean I remember trying the first
titanfall and I was like not my gym and
then I kind of just never went back I
mean it seems like a really fun game but
if it plays like this it's supposed to
then plus a wall running where these
guys that death box
oh wait this box
oh I know I just saw you crouching and
you were keeping up with perishable she
was walking like well that's teammate Oh
enemies where I just got the whole trap
that is a possibly paper I told him over
here okay okay right here Oh No
else our cheese down the watson Wow love
that live again that's really cool do I
I feel like Kent can you use abilities
while you're ghosted like that um I
don't know last time I was actually in
the ability I just ran in yeah if you
compare that with other abilities like
can you like throw a grenade on the
ground and kill yourself and then like
go back to totally like do damage at the
same time like no be cool you can do a
total suicide run like that use octane
or wraiths to suicide bombs yeah like
you go into the other farm run and throw
your like ability and then if it worked
that way it's like yes just because we
saw in the trailer Pathfinder using the
thoth and then using his graphic yeah Oh
interesting
oh snap we're figuring some things out
hearing they okay so I had an epiphany
last night that his tactical might
disabled people's abilities when I was
watching the trailer for like the 30th
time I'm like you know what he like
kills Mirage Mirage doesn't have visible
yes his decoy so as passive didn't
activate disables passive - yeah oh wow
that's what she's kind of cool like
imagine Wraith not being able to phase
or get warnings yes oh don't be
interesting like yeah if their voice is
from the void get disabled I mean I
wouldn't matter at that point you know
you're being attacked but that would be
great for caustic he wouldn't be able to
see in his gas traps either oh wow I see
everything no you I mean so far this
might be one of the best characters in
the game
he's definitely a bit more of a game
changer than crypto yeah fun but yeah he
definitely wasn't technical he's hard to
use and still be like an effective team
player at the same time yeah
all right it's a party here what's the
party yeah
oh no we're landing on the boat right
yeah okay make sure oh why do I do this
damn it
the Wraith stole the blue body shield
where they at uh-huh
he's at the back of the boat she's near
the party hot type of scout this is not
a sniper anymore a dirt who a vault key
someone zipping up someone zipping up
someone taking next to us I heard it I
don't know where the other guy is Oh
being shot from behind I'm looking but I
don't see him I know you're there now
he's there did he go down maybe he's a
ninja
he Juke me I didn't know where he went
yeah I don't know anyone either oh he
broke my ankles Oh max was like I don't
need to call him out I'm just gonna body
this oh I just hear so many good swear I
don't
are you still fighting people yeah cuz
I'm just farming up here
like dude I'm good
apparently not that was kind of a pain
taking a dirt nap he did it I think you
can't be evil and not take the dirt tell
people to take a dirt nap I do need help
though
I will look for syringes nope
not you guys let's meet you to go in the
cargo box okay Oh see you don't need
healing anymore so I can take the med
kit
yeah well let's kick off the party if
that was the last of the squad
unless there's one more as well I kind
of don't wanna use a sentinel but
whatever we're gonna try out new stuff
did you start the party yeah okay I got
two batteries you want them for the
Sentinel yeah I don't know how to do
that let me teach me I wish I could see
chat blue body shield double tap
where are you max there you are see if
it changes anything with your sniper oh
oh
left d-pad to charge okay well I'm just
gonna wait it's just just for the sake
of the stream I think it does like if
you equip it and then oops that's
inspect I like how we need told me about
that I was like a bad sounds fake
[Music]
timers running down pretty much like
slowly yeah it cool so I gotta choose
somebody in the next like five minutes
well it looks like kind of you know like
90 seconds here's something yeah it
looks like it's about 90 seconds from
the timer going down Hank a whole minute
and a half
train looted train is looted yep uh we
can go to train yard vault if people
want to I don't like going to it cuz you
almost always get well third party
misses let's do a salty runback over
here then all right I felt a little more
prepare at this time if you see a
turbocharger though that would be mighty
nice you know it's gone right oh it's
gone oh it's a I think it's
automatically attached to an old store
or to a disrupter devotion sorry
gotcha oh it is that we miss you there's
so much all right I'm gonna fire this
thing off before it disappears just to
see what it feels like oh that was an
anvil I saw earlier wow that sounded
really cool as I say I
I felt that I felt that so high my bones
oops
is that extended sniper a lot of junk
sorry guys fun trying to draw is the
vault Keeks I feel like we're not
actually gonna go to the vault okay oh
did you need that ammo so demanding I'm
already carrying three med kits I
shouldn't just keep loading up on them I
hate syringes we feel like such a waste
of my time I'm really curious to see
really inviting that Octavia might come
on come on come on every time octane
says that I'm like I feel that off I
feel that in my bones all right come on
compadre get up get up get up girl love
his boys lines yeah oh okay he sees me
also where behind us I'm gonna run and
hide because I'm gonna get pressure up
portal I took too long to like alright
yeah let's go are they shooting at you
they just looked at you thank you okay
we should go to the vault get our stuff
and this yeah because we don't have any
defenders to like hold the hold
I think they'll know we're here just try
to get the goods and get it out that
said if they do quarter us I can get out
oh I could put a death totem farther
away so we can safely loot it I'll take
the backpack actually you know that's
what I'm gonna do cuz I know those
people are gonna come this way I don't
have a heavy weapon my eggs
Oh oops I put in the wrong spot um
there's a death put them over here okay
luckily we're in the circle it over here
yeah I'm just touching your totem first
that feels dirty to say yes I'm touching
your totem ah some why do I have it oh
is this how far we can go with your toes
oh you cannot heal your health while
you're being protected by yeah oh really
yeah
oh sure you only take health damage
trail okay no I ran out yeah it's been
destroyed there's people here Oh what
right here right yeah so we're being
third-party delightful I got one nice
I'm famous like I'm I'm locked down I
got hit by the ASA's
a nice oh I ran into your grenade I mean
thermite oh I can't escape this I need
you to Oh No
I'm gonna use sir put them behind to
okay wait what
who's got gold shield idea like can you
stack the gold thing so yourself revive
is faster I don't think so but I know if
you have a gold knock down and gold
backpack when you self revive you'll
still get no it will be the same length
but you'll have shields and health when
you come back yeah which is super cool
yeah yeah the little detail in there
dang most well I guess going well but
then I think on the third party that was
the third or yesterday that vault is my
least favorite vault for that exact
purpose if you get third party and
you're the one who opened the vulture
just you're like there's no getting away
every time I like find a vault key and I
have a teammate he's like let's go to
this one I tempted to just like throw
the vault key like I'm off a cliff I
feel like that is stuffing the most
popular one though it's the closest to
the middle of the map so it's almost
always actually in the first zone
I like going to the one near lava city
but it's also the like furthest from the
moon yeah that was that was nothing at
least popular but it is pretty far that
was fun though yeah
like I said before long as I get frags
[Laughter]
zero kills but he was champion last one
he probably yeah without a squad good
luck trying to get Riven and if you're
not like the first to pick this is
really cool that uh they changed that
little lighting of the map to its like
sunset now hmm yeah it's not as green
yeah which I think they're going for
that right because this thing's like
sucking the region I'm like the volcano
looks much worse than it did a few days
ago oh yeah we're going spy seeing this
one you'll probably die but mm-hmm
it's fine I do want to do like a new
area
[Music]
there's a lot of people Oh got a skin
bag so mean as octene he was like half
the skin migrate because he's like half
metal half human lay his legs so they
should be good friend
what about Pathfinder yeah he already
alluded to it in the trailer they had a
robot boy team that octane Pathfinder
and revenue that's cool I hear the
gunshots there's definitely somebody
here all right here and we do not have
the body shields for this inside the
building here right behind you max all
right oh nice nose when I was chasing
wondering where the heck that last guy
is though
wait work okay he had nothing probably
why he was running that way yeah there's
three white body shields upstairs max if
you need one appreciate this one over
here she's out there I'm no shield I was
a Persia the building you got a blue
body shield and there was a purple I saw
max was fighting fighting and I just
dipped yeah I did not think about
anything when I was like enemy pretty
kill destroy
I do not like using the havoc so someone
else can take that I'll take it hey
here's an extended mag for that gun I
just took so long to clear my car all
right don't be creepy about it resident
that's a lot of death boxes outside yeah
yep I see him happy finder and someone
in there I think that was a wraith so
she probably no knows where we are cuz I
think uh y-yeah see them over there okay
you kill leader I'm try to sneak in God
you crowd walk so fast oh that's cool
all right are they up top
oh no I don't know how to get up without
having enhanced climbing abilities their
right to building some more anything
there another squash yeah it's another
squad oh he has the best thing everyone
over here
do you have your old I already used it
nice there's a
where the heck is he
are you kidding well that happens I mean
there was a lot of squats Atlanta that I
was like definitely more than three or
four dang so the the havoc is just like
you got to hold that lined up now
I guess so yeah the whole special thing
about the havoc though that it could
support to hop up so why even have a
havoc exactly well now at all
well I mean the select fire mode wasn't
even that useful in my opinion anyways I
feel like I did not enough to it should
do 80 damage not 60 damn I thought the
idea behind it was cool I guess all
rifle that could turn into a sniper yeah
but I mean it's a hit scan which is
useful too but actually you know what
has the best sounding effect for a
bullet that tired sounds so cool and I
want to use a man fancy yeah but just
why is it so weak
oh that's cool with the shadow FX went
over to Wraith mm-hmm I say I love every
single time that you pick revenant
before I pick wraith because it has the
shadow Wraith just appearing champions
going down we have to win at least one
game y'all we're going spicy are we
going quiet we actually did pretty well
doing spicy although this is Trainyard
spicy which before the map change was
the most popular blue zone on world's
edge true
well the maybes not as popular because
if there was all these new hot drops to
go to I kind of want to drop like
outside of this area yeah there's like
these little tunnels that lead into it I
think going through one of them let's go
here and then we can attack three of
them yeah yeah sounds like a plan I try
to be a strategic with my pings as as
much as possible
now without context you're just like
pinging all over the place yeah let's
play call of duty this past weekend and
people are like where are they and I'm
like I'm trying to be I can't
it's such a good system every
first-person shooters it I know like I
don't care if it's shameless or not just
just do it just take it steal it give
the people blue
I don't have to select players hello
hello oh that's a bug got another blue
okay
well that's cool I guess Sentinel if
that bugs gonna persist throughout
season four that's gotta be fixed pretty
quick what happened I couldn't pick up
an item oh and a battle royale that is a
pretty bad not ideal yeah all right this
new sniper you know what I'm gonna keep
the alternator because I heard that the
oh nine nine got some massive nerves
I've been really digging the alternator
this past season yeah
even without the disrupter it's still
good hmm I mean it's not like mega
amazing or anything but it's just a
solid gun you want a shield battery for
your sniper rifle Persia wow you want to
shield battery for your sniper rifle
give me the power being it takes a big
one yeah yeah that's kind of there's a
hungry boy
yeah but I'm curious on how much damage
it does if it's what he worth it
alright I was trying to land a shot in
lane as I wasn't sure if I was hit by
one in that time that we were being
third partied in the vault but if I was
it took away almost all of my health in
a single shot oh really
yeah I mean it doesn't go hundred damage
then one well you know times three if
you want that for the sniper where's
that coming from
it sounds like East look at you just
throwing that directly I should probably
get a sniper scope it's a really cool
area mm-hmm I like the color aesthetic
too
I've been really jonesing for world's
edge to get like a skull town like area
like a place where everyone just goes
the name of that town feels like such a
distant memory God there's like all
these cover things that you can get
behind if you're like trying to make
your way up oh here we go
you scared me Achtung
no mirages right here so many mirages
yeah he's weak where'd he go he
invisible I've lost sight so here it
appears up here well then that makes
trace whole squad down octane best way
oh no that one oh I had to reload damn
it
I only saw one behind me solo going for
you oh if we're off right on time
I'm so sad oh good oh I use all my a
murrain and get her sad life
where'd he go uh she ran she ran
somewhere over there she zipped up out
of there I'm wondering if
oh is this arranged for it
yeah there's range for the totem it's
not like you can activate it and run as
far as you want interesting okay can i
Rito to myself don't know I'll have
already use a totem okay interesting
so the one-time use I needed a light
ammo if you see it anyway I can drop
some of mine
yeah can give some line to Oh sharing is
caring
alright I kind of just want explode this
area really quick thank you oh so only
starts recharging once that totem
disappears I wonder if I can shoot Oh
keylogger oh he ran left
it's revving it oh no I'm too behind
what oh gosh okay that worked out well
be nice to have a totem right now a
crater that's scaring me I don't like
that yeah people are weak over here oh
no those fools
with the sniper that was that no without
it changed oh wow so that was a headshot
it was gold I don't know if she had a
gold shield or not oh no no it's
definitely headshot then that means
probably fully charged it has the
strength of a Craver I'm down with that
it probably just downs people with white
body shields on a headshot although I've
noticed that the swapping speed for the
Sentinel was really slow hmm like it
takes a while for you to bring out the
gun but I mean stone every gun needs a
drawback yeah it still sounds pretty
strong damage was already bolt action
yeah it's not like creep man relaying
creepers so an item is it the new m40
noscope tonight see new montages come
out
and I was watching some streamers last
night the way they play oh my god yeah
I'm like let me just be a tense as good
as your pretty good it's fine all right
so I kind of like that sniper but there
was just too many people there yeah it
needs to be a advantageous situation
can't just run in there there's no there
there are two people on that squad that
were apex predators level two yeah
there's the second highest rank in the
entire game I'm not sure if I shout out
background matchmaking is still going on
but it's definitely pouring some people
in that is a strong champion slide over
here wonder if there's any new changes
in other parts of skyhook yeah it looks
really dusty over there like best you
have in normal I thought I got a trophy
guys jump master see building your
second account up pretty soon would be a
predator
oh there are people here with us oh man
delightful longbow I hear someone in my
building I think oh they're upstairs no
bueno
actually no what just for the sake of
close quarters right now I'm gonna take
this what holy crap
all right on my way what hit you just so
I know what I'm walking into
why do I never find body shields when I
land I don't know they definitely found
me there chase me oh that does not go
through all nice there's someone outside
somebody's below us fine I hate you
seriously keep on this building there
Chris oh I have nomads of course oh my
gosh it
Thanks
what that was smart it was bility no
well nice
was that the Watson she got me too
I play a lot of competitive so my go-to
strategy has always finished the kill
might as well at least hook up the stats
a bit exactly I'd like any must dance
give him my stats
yeah matchmaking us really messing us up
right now I mean we're getting kills
kills I'm getting two to four kills
every game he's got me top five yeah
closest we came I think was the very
first game where we got yeah like oh
these guys are good put them in a higher
bracket are you every season you're just
gonna make a fresh account never don't
play any games on it yeah I really want
to mess around the death totem or mm-hmm
really could compare that with certain
skills it can be really good
I like that as a range on it though you
know it had a range on it but it's a
little bit F sense so they're not like
place to death to them here and then
walk I mean you can set up strategies
working like set up a totem have a have
a rate portal there and then like
distract people and I grunt over and die
and then like come back and like portal
away yeah get away scot-free and that's
kind of cool okay
come on guys gotta do this I don't know
where to go
I'm looking behind us to see if we can
do any delayed drops
it's my Old Faithful spot but I'm sure
it's all changed my I say your Old
Faithful spot has been cut in half
yeah like looking back and you see that
one person going the opposite way
because they like drop late or something
yeah talk about like solo operation here
yeah yeah and I'm always wondering when
I see that I'm like is that like an
outlet like that IGN or Kotaku they like
try to grab something because if they
are I understand oh boy I almost always
play octane so every time I see Persia
I think it's an enemy octane and I go to
is shoot it in the face
gosh I really nice pretty close if you
want it you could have it pew pew some
people need them in here I'm ready wish
I really had a body shield yeah yeah
right outside you're looking at you move
away from the door for a sec yeah
[Laughter]
great okay alright where the heck yeah
yeah oh there's someone really close to
us actually use me oh this is a new
legend though you just couldn't reach
her so many feet where the heck are they
all right a cup not getting any voice
warnings hey check in the box
Oh out there good thing he missed I do
not see you sure you yeah you tried to
save me oh my god
cut it was really loud ow
oh he's hurting me Oh a hitter but not
much okay I got one
oh behind me
so whack so take a peek right there
there's just no body shield if I had a
body shield to heal that oh yeah that'd
have been nice I feel like there's
definitely less body she does it feels
like white body shields are spawning in
less off yeah either veteran just such
as I'm lining loose today yeah it's been
like three or four games back to back
where it dropped in there's like either
white body shields or none hmm it's not
promising there's four daily challenges
I'm usually only three a day oh sure
they must have update yeah oh I was just
looking at them like there are but I
can't give two of them on this account
because I don't have Mirage and Watson
[Music]
[Laughter]
does it still give you a challenges for
Heroes you don't have yeah oh that's
kind of rough yep kinda silly actually
you want these points can't happen I'm
trying to figure out like who would best
pair with revenants abilities
I feel like Rafe would I think we should
try something with race portal I forget
that if we can survive that long either
race portal or I do like the idea that
you pose where like you set your death
totem then you set a wraith portal right
next to it and then you just run forward
with race portal and set it at the fight
so that if you do die and go back to the
death totem immediately Worf back yeah
right
it's like a second chance maybe
epicenter has changed
maybe it's icier now wiser than before
I'm going that way don't follow me Oh
somebody's got to compete with caustic
no I don't want the sniper stock don't
worry everyone I have a Mozambique we're
saved I'm taking the g7 that first draft
body shields oh I hear fire like off to
the west that's probably uh Oh was that
the item drop yours had a bullet shot
that's not really heavy that was an item
dropping god awfully loud yeah it's oh
it's been like that for a few weeks now
and it freaks me out every single time
I'm like [ __ ] someone's sniping and I'm
like no no just uh just dropped an item
on the snow I'm not a fan of it like
because I'm very jump scared very easily
I'm just gonna freak myself out every
single time first I take the blue bar
shield that's so nice that would give
you a portal to it all right where we
going I mean I kinda want to keep going
to the new area just yeah exploring it
but at the same time it's gonna be spicy
again we're probably a third fourth
party again the problem is we've been
running in like with low armor and stuff
like that I think yeah with at least
blue body shields and I assume everyone
has two guns apiece I feel much better
about our odds
I actually am oh now so I feel pretty
good let's go max I feel like we've got
some people here all people here I'm
trying to find a climbing point excuse
me oh no of course to give you shield we
were just outside are they upstairs yeah
he's up on the stairs I'm gonna chop him
in he's low houses give me not dead yet
how it's his shield infinite or does it
like maybe I got a block yeah I'm
guessing maybe got above
ding I'm trying to trap them in there
yeah I was like no wonder you didn't run
through the wall he was just waiting
he's just holding yeah that feels like
the strongest that give me his gun
shield has ever been
I like loaded a whole clip of Spitfires
and I thought it cracked but then like
two seconds later you put it back up
again I was like what done actually
don't play so I don't really know how
that [ __ ] works yeah I don't know I uh I
was really dumb I couldn't do anything
usually it's just another white body
shield definitely that he has to
whatever she body shield yeah just add
white I think I shouldn't a peacekeeper
ten because basically it's just burst
damage and he had like he pulled up his
gun and before he pulled up his gun I
shot I mean did a lot of damage and then
turn on the shield
and then I did my second shot basically
didn't no damage to him and then he just
laid me down after that but you know
what he should have done it I should
have done the tactical what's possible
if that does rely on that gun shield to
tank hits for them I'm trying to like
yeah I need to use this cue a lot more
yeah what's the cooldown on that I think
you like 20 seconds so it's not too bad
yeah that's pretty good yeah see decent
better than wraiths yeah man that so
many characters just is so screwed
losing their chassis is their abilities
oh it's gonna be spicy it's fine at
least I'm gonna like hopefully grab a
gun before I die okay I'm gonna try to
land in that one okay please sir before
you kill me let me just pick up a gun
I just can't land in peace give me a
wife and give me get that body shield
fine you shot a limos and egos there's
nobody here with us no one that I found
yeah
oh we're all going to see indirection
yeah I'm gonna the body shield I see his
voice lines are pretty good I'm
surprising the one else dropped here I'm
kinda surprised too I'm guessing this
hasn't been changed at all I don't see
anything different here so yeah pretty
sure everybody's going to the new areas
and so he'll be busy again when people
get bored
do you want to go through the tunnel
towards Overlook sure there might be
like small map changes throughout the
map that they haven't told us he
emphasized the the obvious areas ooh
at some point we should head to sorting
factory and see what's happened to the
set were forges death box well about
that is it still there they put it that
box yeah was there anything in it uh
yeah there's a metal heavy wore around
his neck you could get it as a gun sharp
I'm guessing it might be gone now just
because there's like a limited time
thing yeah just naturally instinctively
do that towards the beginning the game
so I know we always have white or no
body shields and of course you guys have
two purples you love to see it someone
landed on this side yeah that's cool if
there's no like actual max for light
weapons now I mean I know that made that
change a little bit ago but mm-hmm
it's nice to let me have that for real
now but there's just more stuff on the
ground yet to pick up for no reason it's
just more
alright the team that was here before
has picked this place pretty cool okay
well we're in the Rings uh where's the
sorting Factory again oh that's over in
this direction
well he's so edgy all that angst yeah
Oh finally I hear some action of course
it's in the city well are we going here
again I wish I had a better scope from
my sin to nail but are we going into the
city why not I mean it is a new area I
think people have been here hopefully
they still are because I'm bored over
there
we should coordinate the death totem at
the same time yeah I don't have an
optimal loadout for this but let's do it
anyways that you me pinging yeah no I
feel like if somebody else here oh
there's stuffy something else here
where I hear the guys I'm doing
something stupid and heading up don't
understand what anyway it was not stupid
can you see what it told him is in the
map got him that's really loud
let's add some fun into that accident I
didn't know there is a jump at there
dang I hit a lot of people at that no oh
man there are all types of things
happening here
she's stuck in here while she went up
above get her oh oh my goodness she's
still in there nice Oh behind you behind
of course there's another squad you got
your old oh yeah I used it
behind you behind you
wait what happened
that was a grenade that just went off
there must've been another party than
wad yeah I was like wait this is not how
it ends
I just pull out a piece key from like
point-blank range
I can't miss that's just that was pretty
Looney Tunes everyone died that's all
folks
capital C every time let's go straight
action everywhere else and loot and then
go to the city and just have the same
thing happens everything yeah it's been
the same story
I dare it's quite a few people with my
alt I knocked someone whole bunch of
squads and doesn't really matter to us
we're going above and just throwing
grenades way to go
and another squad thought the same thing
when we were damaging them yep I'm
fighting down there yeah I need to be
more pokey with revenant and like not be
running in there I should have I thought
I had to death totem on actually wonder
what happened to it I think it ran out I
ran out tiny seconds I think
thanks so much time running around
looking for them so like you got totem
is good for like one firefight yeah yeah
when we were in that room I was like
give your ability right now but you're
down of like that that would have been
the perfect time yeah
odd the glitch whoa no this is an old
glitch they came back predators
there's so much lightning I know you see
the gates of heaven the only good thing
about the glitch is that it annoys so
many people that regularly yeah that's
all the late drops are relatively free
all right let's just we are the last
group of well that was weird we all
separated for a second knows oh man
there's no way we're the only one with
the blue zone and the Train is here
there is no way we're the only ones here
it's fine why did I go down here Oh
other people got to the Train oh no I
just won a shield ah no there's two
people over here
oh there's two squads over here never
mind
no I get out now I'm like I need your
body shield I picked up the drops was
way too spicy yeah his blue area and the
chin but it's not like we're doing bad I
was a person in a blue body shield who
took on someone with all gold armor I
feel proud about like oh because they
were on the train right yeah
that trains got balut yep
that hasn't changed I just got on the
train and I'm like there's a dropped
purple body shield on it I was a blue
one and I picked it up I'm like oh this
is purchase old sheets it was empty
well I did have a blue that broke and
then I just swapped it for another blue
so there was a few I think broken blue
yeah that train
oh the first 30 seconds let's go back to
hmm
wonder if you can use crypto sewers
synthetic nightmare more difficult to
hit was that mean a little profile oh is
that it
I just saw it like half the sentence
sounds like what's that on the bottom of
the yeah that's a low profile perk where
it's gives a smaller hitbox but it's uh
just takes 5% more damaged and lifeline
at Wraith had that same perfect anything
cuz they're so tiny yeah that's the way
that balance hitboxes oh it's calling to
you like go over there again it's the so
the city's been split the new harvesters
there and then there's the tiny area
near epicenter okay
well let's uh let's let's go here and
then we can squid on over to the the
Forge oh we still haven't checked out
after the Forge death is still there we
didn't accomplish what we set out to do
I mean we were kind of getting oh I'm
gonna die I'm the worst at landing
confirmed no coming Wow I suck I lost to
someone with no body shield no I will
make my way over there well I'm gonna
roll in with her chuckling I'm just
going solo kind of just like Bobby she
loved sweets
people on us I see your weight one oh
dang so there's like oh that's someone
shooting through the window or are they
in here they're on top of us excuse me
do it Persia do it I don't think he has
a body shield unless that with him my
banner if you respond me I can be acting
as bait for you I got you this why I
like this fan right here
yeah I'm all right
yay we did it guys proud of us still got
a lot ways to go there I don't see
anyone else in the area
that means that could just be hiding
inside buildings you need a shield Saul
Persia all right where's my body see
that's right I didn't actually find
anything
there's nothing all right
rocking peacekeeper and Eva dang saggy
life it's a pretty big area wonder uh
what the trajectory is going up I wonder
if I can like shoot it upwards and then
like bait somebody to come back Sonny
you can do that with frag grenades did
it there Jen there used to be a lot more
water up here
[Music]
the spring I don't think so playing
green I think some of its dried up our
resources we don't make sense with the
whole purchasing the planet thing l star
let's try you out of the non Golden Gun
yeah I'm just the L star does so much
damage but the bullets are just so yeah
I like unless you're at point-blank
range you're doing anything or you're
leading shots really well and it's
really hard to get killed of that thing
I could use an extended life and or
heavy mag okay if you come across one
okay I'm gonna just test this really
quick oh it starts so recharging all
ready to kill oh that's pretty cool
so like by itami it lands you're like
already 15 seconds away from [ __ ] on
your second one that's pretty nifty so I
guess he's meant to be used as a
character just like it's constantly
pushing on people yeah oh yeah you're
speeding crouched there like push push
again just keep pushing we are literally
in their face
I know I can really don't want to go
into the city Cole's gonna spend ten
minutes running around waiting to die in
like one minute yeah I'm not a fan is
very hard we made it to top eight again
I heard a sniper shot in like the
Northwest area god I totally forgot
there's a cardinal compass on this game
we're so used to using pings
yeah that's Crouch walk speed is amazing
brag about it no it sounds sort of close
yeah back to the city we go you guys
yeah
excuse me someone's trying trying to hit
somebody oops okay so you can scale this
whole building this is like the very max
height they can climb that's pretty high
yeah Oh it'll be here the death totem
right here
I see oh jeez he told me quick Wraith
has no body shield oh they have a red mo
just always assume every squad has a
revenant oh no the ring really where's
the other guy he's up here somewhere
I hear him oh no you scared me so much
oh no tearing him up oh let me go please
Abril like what ring I am dead this is
nothing you'll die when I say you guys
max why
well Oh No I'll get us banner as soon as
I see em person decides oh man it's just
by himself so you could just guard that
I say if he runs for the zone purge it
just kill nice nice room head okay just
rolling together I'm not gonna be able
to revive you I feel like but I'm gonna
try my best
oh I mean you can but yeah we're
probably got there party yeah exactly
here's someone with a zip line and
someone healing that's probably him
that's above but he's about Jordan
I'm just keep going try to get I'll
catch up with Persia this is dangerous
definitely near you on top of a building
hmm yeah this apart this the safest
traffic yeah if you come back
oh wait where was that from well I made
the right choice and going to this one I
guess there's somebody else okay he's
over there oh boy oh man this is rough I
see him down there he's by the end of
the bridge
hurry are we gonna go back to Jordan I
feel like it enough time let's just go
to just go towards the ring I say I'll
we'll catch up with you
are you just hiding right now I know
this battle over here good loot I just
wanted to grab it real quick I don't
have ICM no okay well they see us and I
don't have anything so I'm gonna let's
uh let's just run this way hey time for
like thirty all the ring no I can't make
that we have to fight this yeah you guys
do your thing over there we're gonna run
around this isn't gonna end well you're
gonna be you want to trade one of my
guns for you this is why I hate they'll
start I don't have anything
oh wow this hurts the ring hurts ding
let's hide in this cave no we're dead I
want another kill my box may death box
alright guys it is a little past 12:30
do you want to do one more yes okay sure
always do one more you know will do Oh
all party members must reach level 10
[Music]
I'm sorry I've been learning a lot at
least though
all right sweaty gamer mode everybody
lean forward last game the more you lean
forward the more horsepower yeah yes
it's just science that's proven this is
the one
yeah the interesting thing about the
silence abilities you can do that while
you're healing while you're shooting so
it's oh really that's really it's like
it's like Octane's thing where you could
just do it while you're doing other
things alright I'm ready
Wayne kill
matchmaking alright give us a good spot
there's no pressure
yeah the survey camp again it's a bit of
a long drop yeah let's go for it I think
I possibly could glide over there if not
you can just go train tunnel and yeah
just run through we have no-one
following us yeah I doubt there'll be
anybody over there yeah no one's going
yeah yeah I can make that just be lying
here take a little jog over there
overboard
myzel just booked it Oh gold in there I
did I didn't even see I was trying to
pick up the blue I'm like why isn't it
picking up Mike Oh why'd he just grab
the gold or because you're already
perfect Wow sometime oh there's a new
zip line
oh wow where does that go
just go towards a camp hmm that's more
of a get out of Dodge supplies you have
to go in that's how you know you play a
lot of eight pegs you notice there was
an extra zip line me I wish you can make
your own voice lines and upload them and
see here's that gun rack how dare they
he's my you twenty in this gun rack what
a waste of error
it's quiet too quiet
Oh since um it's always like hot or cold
and yeah there's no in-between you guys
see a backpack to the lining in okay I
can't play around with this anymore
Ulta jewel inside or something spinning
oh cool that's kind of cool so yeah I
think he was playing with it and is a
character trailer oh really
yeah it's like a loaded die or something
death is a game I mean that will be
fitting and I'm the dungeon master
[Laughter]
I always die when I'm trying to reload
that's like my being in this game
yeah the reload times are pretty harsh
I'll be looting and and I'm like where
you guys and you guys are like on the
other side oh that's so far okay never
mind
yeah I know I was like I'm really far
there you go closer back there's even a
lot if you fancy such a thing thank you
[Music]
you got it Wow so when disrespect you
late
yeah I want to see the banter between
caustic and I hear robot boy thank you
guys
I heard a caustic trap Oh hail oh I'm
stuck behind a crate you know and I'm
just gonna stay here okay they're
reviving I got stuck
Oh God Oh got him
kostik what okay I don't have any
healing trap right there trap right
there he's gonna pick up his squad mate
I think
oh hey oh I don't have much friends what
I can't get to you again everyone I'm
inside the whole squad how are you alive
max I'm looking at your health right now
and uh it's the desktop I used it they
have so much good stuff
we will shield battery for my again I
hear someone or something flying no I
like white oh wait no no I don't want to
charge it yet I really want to use this
[Music]
charged up Sentinel rifle all right do
you guys need uh Nets I do
blue did every minute they have jeez
that sound is so loud god I don't like
the head alright let's go over here I
love his voice lines and apparently his
voice actor is the same as Reinhart oh
cool yeah pretty sure crypto is Genji oh
really
yeah I was pretty crossover yeah well we
did it I was like as that can be else
footsteps oh aren't that close to me
yeah I got two knockdowns with the
triple take at point-blank range just
now yeah oh nice oh you must knock down
the gun revived yeah to knock down to
myself well I don't want to go here
again I know well let's see what the
ring is oh we're right in the middle
cool alright
well let's take a look around I'm gonna
you can go in
I see a good brother old uh where it
came from that direction okay it's a
good ways off probably 400 500 meters
all right
I could take high road and defend up
there deep doo-doo deep doo-doo
yeah this is very world's edge like a
lot of huff in it can't believe we never
found a choke
I'm sniping with a triple take that has
over here
damn stupid Pathfinder I think trying to
revive his teammates he's looking at to
this uh respawn beacon up here he's so
low he's like one shot literally one
shot oh my goodness
stop running jeez I'm gonna pick you up
okay yeah I can go up in Jordan he's
healing up somewhere we have a teammate
somewhere oh I was a third party I know
yeah it's a third party well he also has
teammates because he didn't go down
immediately
nice good stuff where's the other one
he's running no but just revive me for
now and then okay okay you need to heal
I need eight seconds of your time though
okay okay I live I live again someone
definitely up here up top okay no more
ham oh [ __ ] they have light thank God no
no no that didn't work out very well
where are they oh well yeah at least we
got out of top five oh well you win some
you Lisa yeah there was never just like
us mrs. a-team this is like old kings
canyon oh look any third party the pond
third party let's see that was fun I
think I'm liking revenant a lot like
he's definitely one of my favorites I
think he might be better than Wraith in
my thing yeah exactly a game changer and
his ability is just so funny yeah she's
like no stop so good yeah it was cool
hope you guys enjoyed and if you didn't
obviously already knows season four of
apex legends is live and it's pretty fun
so you guys should check it out and of
course if you're looking for more apex
content make sure you at check out our
website and our YouTube channel because
we've got a lot of awesome apex stuff
like our year one year what is it your
one retrospective that's up right now
it's great check it out and for everyone
who tuned in thank you so much and make
sure you're tuning in every single
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific time because
that's when we play and you should join
us but until next time we'll see you
guys later peace out bye bye you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you